priya priya Natarajan is an assistant
professor at in both astronomy and
physics here at Yale she got her
bachelor's from MIT and her doctorate
from Cambridge University in the UK and
her specialty is hunting dark matter now
when I heard dark matter I thought it
was it was that stuff that was in my
refrigerator but she's going to talk
specifically about the dark matter
that's in galaxies and she's talked
about this worldwide and she has so many
significant achievements at such a young
age as well so I'm very excited to learn
about Dark Matter and so perhaps you can
join me in welcoming dr. Natarajan who's
going to talk to us a little bit about
it thank you thanks so much for that
very generous introduction and it's a
real pleasure and privilege to be able
to talk to all of you today and I'm
really glad you're here despite the rain
what I want to talk about is a very very
important Enterprise in astrophysics
astronomy and cosmology today which is
trying to understand the contents of the
universe and it turns out that current
observational data suggests that much of
the universe more than 90% of it in
terms of matter as in fact dark and it's
dark because we don't know what it is we
do not know its composition what we do
know is that it has gravity that it
exerts the force of gravity it exerts an
attractive force on objects that are
nearby and we know that there's copious
amounts of it everywhere including our
own galaxy and that it is very very
crucial you might wonder I mean okay
well we don't know what it is fine let's
just move on
we can't why because the fate of our
universe is crucially determined by the
contents of the universe and I hope to
lead you through some of sort of the
basic tenets in cosmology all of which
are observational II supported that will
help you understand
why the quest for dark matter is such an
important and crucial exercise for
cosmology today so I start off as I said
by giving you a little bit of an
introduction trying to sort of lay the
land of what is it that we try to do
when we do cosmology because what we
want to do is to characterize the
properties of the universe we want to
understand its size its contents its
structure obviously how it formed how
its evolving and how it's going to end
and dot matter plays a very very crucial
role in determining the story the entire
story and it's very important from the
very beginning and as I said one of the
crucial things about our lack of
knowledge at the moment is the fact that
we do not know if dark matter is charged
we have no idea
okay and as all of you who've done sort
of you know have felt static when you
take your clothes off in winter that's a
very fundamental property so we really
don't know what dark matter is made of
however we've made very very important
strides as I hope to lead you through to
show you some of the most beautiful
pieces of data that the Hubble Space
Telescope has ever taken and the Hubble
Space Telescope has been very very
important in transforming this field as
I'll show you so as I said we first
start off with some preliminaries with
which we'll try and try and explain to
you what the basic properties of the
universe are and some of my motivation
in doing this is I want to also sort of
pique your curiosity so you'll all go
back home going to Google or something
and start searching for some of these
things and learn more so I'm going to
give you just a very sparse introduction
because I want to lead you right into
the quest for dark matter and hope to
lead you through sisters of this journey
in a historical fashion the way it has
happened in cosmology so some of the
important properties of the universe
that we need to understand and sort of
keep track of are that it's static right
this was the idea that people had before
we had any observations of the motions
of galaxies so what I'm planning to do
is to try and show you that these are
the
years and how as part of science some of
the older ideas get replaced by the
newer newer and current ideas as we
gather more and more data so in the
1700's and 1800's people thought there
was no motion in the universe was static
there was no motion it was infinite and
it had to be infinite to balance all the
matter of course at that point they also
realized they did not know there was
dark matter in the 1800s right so they
saw they knew there was a solar system
they did other planets and possibly
other stars and other nebulae which were
other galaxies then it occurred to them
that oh well you know a finite universe
has to have an edge I'm just trying to
motivate the idea of gravity here so you
know why gravity even on the scale of
the universe is so important some
material at the edge of the universe
would clearly feel if there was an edge
would feel the inward pull of gravity
and it would start moving in however
they never saw any motions so they said
they can't be an edge so the universe
must be infinite right but there are
lots of problems with an infinite
universe and some of those will become
clearer as we move along so for example
this is a question that I want you to
think about and I would be happy to have
volunteers come up with suggestions at
the end of the talk as to why is the
night sky dark ok so there were many
many there were many ideas sophisticated
and unsophisticated the first of which
was oh the Sun set of course so that's
what the night sky is dark however the
fact that the night sky is dark is very
crucial has a crucial bearing on the
size of the universe because in an
infinite universe can the night sky ever
be dark and that's something I want you
to think about and we can come back to
it at the end of the talk so in an
infinite universe of course you'd have
an infinite number of stars there will
be infinite star light should be
infinitely bright that's not the case at
all
so obviously the solution is not that
the universe necessarily isn't spatially
infinite but that isn't infinitely old
and this is the statement that I want
you to demystify at the end of the talk
and I think you will have a
very clear idea of why that is so the
obvious reason is we can't see all parts
of the universe but we can see what's
nearby so that this is the sort of that
was to give you an idea of the
progression of how people thought about
size and the scale of the universe so
let's talk so let me give you like three
nice technical terms that are easy to
remember and there are very physical so
the modern idea what we know from
current observations is the universe is
homogeneous on very large scale
I eat material galaxies are fairly
uniformly distributed and you might
wonder why is this important it's a very
important crucial mathematical property
which we will see manifests itself in a
very nice way observational e we also
think that the universe is isotropic it
looks the same to all observers this is
another very tricky but neat thing about
the universe that there is no special
direction there is no special Center and
we'll come to that so these two
properties very simple ideas that all
the material all the galaxies are
uniformly distributed and that there is
no preferred direction in the universe
combined together from the basis of
current cosmology and that's called the
cosmological principle and you might
wonder what why is this such a deep
principle obviously one of the things
I'm not showing you here are all the
mathematical equations and this is in
fact a very crucial mathematical
property these two quantities are
actually mathematical properties that
lead you to the current observed
universe but they have a very nice
physical simple basis so these are the
basic assumptions that we are starting
out with and observations show us that
those assumptions are true the other
thing you might have all wondered is
that you know I'm trying to persuade you
that even in the universe what was that
oh yes even when I'm teaching it often
tells me your battery is 30% charge at
least it's fully charged today that's
good
so the other thing you might wonder is
I'm talking to you about gravity and my
you might think it's true and Apple
falls and it falls down to the earth
because of gravity but you know do these
laws have to hold everywhere in the
universe
in fact as physicists the assumption
that we make is that all these unit laws
universal laws actually hold everywhere
in the universe and that's very crucial
because you can imagine that you won't
get very far if you think that on the
Andromeda galaxy gravity doesn't work
and it's a completely different set of
laws because we wouldn't really be able
to make any sense of our observations if
we don't make this assumption to start
with and of course we can test these
assumptions which we do and this one
holds out pretty well as well as we will
see okay I don't know why it's not
moving all right how did I do that okay
so now the current models of the
universe try to produce a universe that
follows this cosmological principle and
the principle of universality okay so
all the models all the mathematical
models that we're going to try and test
have these properties to start with the
question is as I keep repeating that the
observations are the final test right so
these are the assumptions that you start
with but the question is whether the
observations hold up so what I want to
show here is one other very very crucial
property of the universe that is a bit
tricky to understand but it's very very
crucial okay so you might have all heard
that the universe started 14 billion
years ago with a big bang so the natural
idea that we have in our head of a big
bang was you know sort of like a bomb
like an explosion that happened in one
particular location so that analogy
doesn't quite work because the Big Bang
happened everywhere it didn't happen in
a special place because whatever is ever
space was there when the Big Bang
happened was everywhere at that time
okay so that's a slightly difficult
concept
but basically the idea is that there is
no single center to the universe there
is no special place in the universe okay
every point in the universe is
equivalent so you can call any point the
center any and every point the center of
the universe and you might wonder yep
what do you mean by the Galactic hub
there are galaxies that group together
by gravity but that doesn't mean that's
the center of the universe so let me
just try to explain why there is no
center of the universe so one of the
observations that is made is that you
see galaxies around us receding away
from us okay
and what that means is that the universe
is in fact expanding okay if there was a
preferred Center to the universe all
galaxies would be receding only from
that particular place now if we move a
spectrograph to the Andromeda galaxy
which is the galaxy nearest to us you in
fact find that with respect to the
Andromeda galaxy everybody else is
receding away too so the concept of
having one Center from which everything
is flowing away it just doesn't work at
all so that is the sort of
incontrovertible proof that the universe
itself is expanding which means there is
no special center and I think the
easiest way to think about this is to
think of the universe basically as a
piece of fabric okay and we are all all
galaxies we are all embedded in this
fabric and in fact rather than these
galaxies moving away from each other or
from a center what's really happening is
the fabric itself is expanding okay so
that's what's really happening so this
fabric is in fact technically also
called the space-time fabric okay so
it's just a sheep you can think of it as
a sheet and the sheet analogy works
really well because the presence of mass
in the universe causes little bumps in
this sheet so think of a sheet - think
of a bedsheet or something and you drop
an apple into it and you
a little bump right if you hold it taut
from the sides you make a little bump
that's really that's the best analogy
that you can make to galaxies in the
universe basically have this sheet
that's stretched and that's in fact
stretching and expanding as I just told
you and all the galaxies and other
objects in the universe are causing
little bumps in this sheet they are not
keeping the sheet straight okay they're
causing little sort of bumps as we go
along and those bumps are going to be
very very crucial because those bumps
define the geometry of the universe how
bumpy the space-time is tells you
something about the shape of the
universe the future of the universe as
well as the geometry of the universe as
we'll see now you might ask okay great
you know I understand we're expanding
the sheet is expanding are we expanding
into something no we're not because I've
told you the universe itself is this
sheet so we're not expanding into
anything else space-time itself is
expanding so these are slightly tricky
concepts but you know I feel I thought
that you might wonder oh is this going
to mean they're very gonna have many
more parking spaces you know something
of relevance today right you want to
park as close as possible but alas now
this is where we come back so what one
of the concepts that I've just told you
about this idea of the universe being a
sheet is one of the major achievements
of Einstein's general relativity and in
fact it was this concept that he
developed which has been the backbone of
all of cosmology and fundamental to
understanding structure of the universe
so this idea that the universe can be
thought of space time can be thought of
as a sheet in which the presence of
galaxies cause little bumps is a major
insight that Einstein had and I'll just
show you when we map dark matter in the
universe it's very crucial to have this
picture right because remember if you're
trying to map if I'm trying to map and
do a cartography on New Haven or
something it's very very important
to know the definition of Terra Firma
okay what is the soil
what is ground what am i Matt what is
what am i mapping stuff on right so it's
very important to know whether there
that there is a ground and there are
objects on the ground if I'm going to do
cartography similarly in the universe if
I'm gonna map dark matter I really need
to know where the hills when the valleys
are and what's going on right and so
general relativity tells you that the
structure of the universe is such that
the presence of masses cause little
bumps in this sheet and the one other
thing I don't know if you caught got me
when I said that we want to think of the
universe as space-time in one of whom
what did she mix up space and time
because actually in our universe space
and time are very intricately linked so
in order to specify an event in the
universe you have to specify not only
where it happened but when it happened
okay you know unlike for us you know we
can specify we can say well you know I
drove in from Hamden and sure if we know
if we need to figure out how long it's
going to take to drive from there we
need to specify the time but we can
uniquely describe events in our daily
lives by just talking about either when
they happen or where they happen we
don't necessarily have to put them
together in the universe you cannot
describe an event uniquely unless you
say when it happen and where it happened
anyone has any ideas as to why it's
important to specify when something
happen in the universe
yep absolutely absolutely I think she
has hit a very very important point
which leads on to the fact that one of
the reasons we need to do that is the
speed of light is finite okay light
travels at a finite speed and it's
something that we don't experience in
our daily life I mean we might have
noticed that it takes it takes eight
minutes for light that's emitted from
the Sun to reach us but
it's not something we experienced right
I mean eight minutes is not that long
however if you think of the Sun is the
closest star to us however if you think
of all the galaxies that we're gonna be
seeing in a little while there are
hundreds of millions of light years away
from us it takes light a finite time to
reach us from those galaxies so in fact
we see those galaxies in their youth we
don't see them as they are today we see
them as they were a hundred million
years ago when light lost left those
galaxies now this would be really nice
right I mean if this was of consequence
to us you would be seeing not me but a
picture of me when I was an infant right
now right unfortunately for us it's not
relevant for only because the speed of
light for anything that has to do with
our day-to-day activities is practically
it's very fast
no and you pick up the phone your
signals work immediately right there's
no delay whereas when we are talking
about astronomical objects the fact that
the speed of light is finite is
consequential so what do we know now
about the universe so this is the
starting point before we start mapping
probing in the universe we think that
the universe is uniformly expanding okay
and this law where I said objects nearby
to us are receding away from us was
discovered by this astronomer Edwin
Hubble
so it's named after him it's called the
Hubble law and if the universe were not
expanding uniformly and sort of doing it
sort of King Keeley you know different
places have different expansion speeds
then you would not be seeing as I said
the galaxies around us uniformly going
away from us right some would be coming
towards us some would be going away in
fact we don't see that for those of you
who want to whet your appetite with a
little bit of mathematics the only
equation I have here today but something
that's very simple and you would want to
know this remember I told you that these
objects are receding with a particular
velocity so that's a speed so that's a
distance traveled per unit time and that
is proportional to the distance from us
so the objects that are closest to us
are receding not as fast as the objects
that are further away from us
okay and that this little h0 that you
see here is what Hubble found as a as a
constant it says this is why it's called
Hubble's law this number is called
Hubble's constant and you might say why
is she telling us about this now the
interesting thing about our current
universe is that you need to specify six
numbers just six numbers to tell you
everything about the universe the
content of the universe the geometry of
the universe the fate of the University
and the start everything okay and this
is one of the important numbers that
characterizes our universe one can think
if there was another universe there are
theories that suggest that there might
be other universes from which we don't
have enough time for light to have
traveled to us to tell us anything about
them but they could potentially exist
and this number would be very different
for a different universe for our
universe this number is about 65 and you
might say why 65 special it's not
particularly special that's what we
measure okay so this is a number that we
go out and try to measure as
cosmologists as I said the objects that
are farther away from us move much
faster that's just a reef mate statement
of this mathematical law and you might
say oh that just suggests let's go back
there's going to suggest that we're at
the center of the universe right but
we're not as I said the reason being the
reason being that you could make the
same measurement from another galaxy and
you see the same law again you might say
how do you make the same measurement
from the other galaxies well you get
light from different galaxies and the
light from different galaxies have
different characteristics and we can
therefore separate out the bit that has
to do with the motions of the galaxies
which we now do routinely and we find
that this hubble law is valid from the
perspective of the little person who is
living on Andromeda so clearly there is
no center to the universe
okay so one other sort of crucial fact
we want to know before we start mapping
the universe and looking for dark matter
is understanding that space has
curvature from on the sheet that I told
you about in fact it's not a flat sheet
I already told you that it has little
bumps
the question is in and of itself does it
have any shape to start with how is it
stretched and the space is really
synonymous with what we call our
universe it's being stretched by the
expansion which is being put right and
it's being uniformly pulled from all
sides and how much it is both depends on
whether this sheet yep
did you have a question oh you were just
stretching your arm okay so it depends
how much you are stretching depends on
how flat you are to start with right so
if you have a completely flat sheet you
have no shape to it it's just a flat
sheet it's very boring okay so this is
just a visualization of that so I
appreciate if our little sheet which is
our universe was completely flat this is
what it would look like but okay and the
interesting thing is you know triangles
drawn on such a sheet the sum of the
angles add up to exactly okay so all the
properties that you know and work you
know on our piece of paper when we are
doing the calculations in school they
work but that's a boring description for
the whole universe okay so our patch of
the universe where we live
looks pretty much flat because we know
our angles add up to 180 degrees
right so the piece of the universe that
we live in
looks locally flat and you might say
well that's a bit confusing it's
actually very simple just think about it
when you're driving from here to the
Peabody Museum it doesn't matter if the
earth is round or flat or whatever
however if you're sailing from here to
Australia it's important right it's
absolutely important so that's what's
happening in the universe we live on a
very small patch of the universe and the
patch that we live in is just it might
as well be flat but it doesn't mean that
it's flat overall okay so let's see what
interesting shapes the universe might
have you won't be saying hmm why should
about the shape of remember I keep
telling you that the fate of the
universe is determined by its geometry
and its contents okay so that's where
we're going now if it had positive
curvature then the universe would be
like a sphere and the sum of the angles
of a triangle would not add up to 180
degrees okay if you have negative
curvature which in my opinion is the
most interesting it's mathematically the
most complicated okay then it would look
like this and this would be like one of
those potato chips like my favorite
potato chip looks like that okay now
let's get our final key concepts in
place if the universe is expanding it
must have been smaller and if we go back
far enough we reach the Big Bang so this
story the story of how we start off with
an initial condition of the Big Bang
start off with some geometry and end up
with all the galaxies that we see around
us is what we call cosmogony which is
through the scientific equivalent of the
tales that every culture every religion
has had to make sense of the universe
except here we have empirical data for
our cosmogony so the current theory the
Big Bang Theory there were two very
important people I know they're very
glum looking I chose these pictures
because they were so serious looking and
I thought okay you know what I want
everyone to see they were serious guys
actually and they did a lot of
interesting mathematics and I mean the
reason I think they were phenomenal was
because they came up with a description
of the right mathematical model for the
universe well before there was any
observational data so they really had
some they had some an incredible insight
okay an insight that was not necessarily
guided by data that was already sitting
around they had they had some enormous
mathematical insight that said okay you
know let's try and the you know I mean
they weren't all around by what they had
to do they said okay here's the universe
let's try and find a few equations that
will describe it and Alexander Friedmann
and LaMotta did this independently one
of the reasons I chose these two people
is I wanted to also point out that one
things of cosmology is that when Russia
and Europe with the rest of the West
were quite separated intellectually and
politically everything happened in
parallel but you know what they didn't
exchange journals so nobody knew what
they had done and nobody knew what these
guys had done these guys did they didn't
know what each other was doing so in
fact science wise it turns out to be
really fruitful you had two completely
independent groups that didn't talk to
each other in fact never wanted to talk
to each other and found the same things
and found the same formulations so now
of course when we give credit we have to
be really careful and make sure that we
give credit to people who did it
simultaneously in both systems okay so
now we are almost ready to go to look at
Dark Matter and you might say oh okay so
what's this fate of the universe
business so the geometry of the universe
and that's what is coded here remember
this is the spherical that's the flat
and this is the Pringle the fate of the
universe from the Big Bang that point
refers to the Big Bang and this is
sometime in the future we are somewhere
here okay that's today this is cosmic
time so the fate of the universe whether
you grow this is the size of the
universe whether you grow and keep
drawing are you kind of turnover and
what is this point referred to do people
know what this is exactly the Big Crunch
right so the question is where we are on
one of these three curves determines our
final fate if we are unfortunately stuck
here then there's going to be a Big
Crunch at some point however if we are
luckily on one of these things are going
to keep coasting along however remember
none of us ever have to worry right
because at 14 billion years or so we're
here so we're talking many many yep sure
sure absolutely yeah the other one would
have ended well before them okay so this
as I said so this is these are
mathematical solutions which are the
fate of that space-time sheet okay so
what is going to happen in this solution
which is that which leads to the Big
Crunch is that space-time instead of
expanding which it does up to a point
after a certain point starts to contract
okay so it starts to contract the sheet
instead of moving up outwards uniformly
starts to contract inward and eventually
so it starts contracting and in terms of
what would happen to galaxies and so on
galaxies would start to collide with
each other okay
much more frequently and they would
destroy each other so at the Big Crunch
by the time you reach the Big Crunch and
you approach the Big Crunch ie when the
sheet is contracted enough to become
smaller and smaller
there will be no galaxies needless there
will be no life bye then okay so the
interesting thing about the Big Crunch
is all the structure in the universe
that you see today would be completely
wiped out so it's almost like running
the movie that has happened so far
backward and you will be going back and
you would go back to a singularity and
that would be that singularity is what
we call the Big Crunch anyone see me
what is singularity it would be to the
point that would most resemble the Big
Bang okay yep it could it absolutely
could because then with that would that
would mean that we are living in a
universe that's basically oscillating
between expanding dying
regenerating itself and so on so forth
yeah absolutely yep
yeah no no will be will be on one or the
other no actually they wouldn't well
there would be there would be an end in
the sense that at some point it might
become very inefficient for galaxies to
form so no new galaxies would form and
the galaxies that are existing would
just kind of age and die okay so you
wouldn't form galaxies as fast you would
still keep forming them but not as fast
okay so in some sense that sort of
universe is sort of an eternal universe
I mean you really want to die out
completely I think there was one other
question right yep yeah gosh absolutely
yeah yeah I said she was right so the
question is what she's trying to ask is
that least two solutions or is it a he
sorry what what they're trying to ask is
what is the difference between these two
solutions okay and is it going to be
that in one of the solutions what you
really ends up happening is that the
rate of formation of galaxies isn't
really all that much affected compared
to the other so let me just explain this
very very quickly what the difference
between these two solutions is so all of
you are sort of familiar with the
concept of acceleration which is the
rate of change of speed right velocity
so you put the gas on the gas pedal on
and you brake you know what you're
changing is the velocity so what is
really different about these two
solutions is that one of them is
accelerating and the other one is
decelerating okay but in a very slow
rate at such a slow rate that the one
that is decelerating is never going to
ultimately slow down and go to the
crunch okay it's never going to
ultimately slow down that the expansion
yeah
okay why don't we talk about this why
don't we talk about this later I think
there's a little bit of confusion here
which we'll talk about while we - why
don't we talk after okay so as far as
what we are concerned with at the moment
this universe which is a flat universe
okay is what our universe looks like if
we look right around us okay
however when we look further out so what
do you might what you might think okay
how do we figure out which solution we
are sitting on okay I'll be sitting on
they totally flat universe are we
sitting on an open universe right and an
open universe can also look flat over a
very small scale although the universe
itself is open and looks like the
outside of the pringle chip however our
current universe is in fact a flat
universe okay and this flat universe as
I told you although it's a little boring
it's actually the mathematically the
simplest in terms of the solution and
the implications and so on so forth
however what we need to make the
universe flat is matter okay so we need
matter in the universe to make it flat
and what the current data is telling us
that our universe is flat we need a lot
of matter okay and what we do is we go
out there we measure the we look at the
starlight from all the galaxies around
us we count up all the mass in all those
stars that are giving out that light
we do a full inventory we go and count
up all the gas molecules we see in the
universe and we say okay how much mass
is that is that enough mass to make the
universe flat in fact you find that that
is not enough mass to make the universe
flat and therefore you need some other
unaccounted for mass to make the
universe flat and we need dark matter
so let's come back to why is it called
dark I mean it's obviously called dark
because we don't know anything about it
whatever cosmologists don't know
anything about something they just say
dark whatever yes so there is also no
radiation there is no light there's no
x-rays there's no gamma rays there's no
visible light there's nothing that's
emitted by dark matter okay yep it's
doing what's right you mean it's
oscillating yeah those solutions are
still popular in the literature but I
mean the people were writing papers but
there's no observational data to support
them so he asked about these idea of
oscillating universes and a diagram for
one of those universes would look like
this repeating itself okay and we don't
I mean those there's no evidence that
the current data supports a universe
like that okay so now let me go on
directly now let's let let's move on to
start mapping dark matter so this is the
dependence of the velocity dependence on
radius so the Sun is here presume that
the Sun is here and we're looking at the
distance from the Sun for all the
planets okay so all the planets are
along here and what do you find is the
the speed with which Neptune or Pluto
are going around the Sun is much lower
than the speed at which we are going
around the Sun okay so that's what this
plot is showing you the closer in you
are the faster you are moving and why is
that that is so because the closer in
you are you are feeling
the effects of the gravity of the Sun
much more now I'd say okay great I buy
that that makes sense
now let's see if I move this argument if
I apply the same argument to a galaxy
and I say okay
this galaxy is the center which is here
and there are stars so this is these are
all what you see here is little specks
are all stars and the stuff that you see
smooth this also starlight okay we were
not able to there's so many stars right
here that their light looks pretty
smooth that you don't pick them out
whereas what you see here are stars and
globular clusters so let's look at this
galaxy and say a star that is sitting
right here versus a star that is sitting
here versus here versus here let's make
the analogy with the solar system
what should the motion of those stars
look like what do we expect okay so let
us consider so this is just looking at
the same galaxy I've turned it upside
down so we can see see it much more
clearly so it's a spiral galaxy with all
these arms much like our own and this is
the center of the galaxy and we are
measuring our distance from there we're
moving out and you say okay so let's
look at stars at different locations and
see what their speeds are like and we
can see how fast they're orbiting around
the galaxy and the thing what turns out
to be the important quantity that
determines how fast they're moving is
the amount of mass that is inside their
location so if I look at a star at
radius R what is relevant is all the
maths that is inside of are okay that's
what determines how fast this star here
will be moving so what do we expect so
we expect something like the solar
system plot that I just showed you you
expect things right in the center to be
moving a lot faster and then things
falling off what do we see we don't see
that right we see that the speed is in
fact totally the opposite of what we
would imagine it's very slow in the
center kind of picks up it stays flat
stayed flat as far as we can see
remember we are still mapping the Stars
right we're still looking at stars and
seeing the motions of the stars
so at some point we're running out of
stories in this galaxy because you know
it's very faint we don't see that we see
sort of an edge to the galaxy right so
this is sort of roughly the galaxy edge
what is intriguing is that you're seeing
that it's flattening off rather than
falling so let me show you some real
data so this is sort of very new data
for four different galaxies so these are
the images of the galaxies these are
Hubble Space Telescope images and you
are these lines show you the slits in
the direction along which you're
measuring the speeds of the stars so
this is where you're getting your ours
from the various locations
okay so along here you're making the
measurement what you're finding is
you're starting nicely from zero you
have a little bump and then you're
flattening off and in pretty much every
case you keep going and you flatten off
so there doesn't seem to be an edge of
the galaxy that coincides with when the
stars run out because if there was an
edge to the galaxy you would see this
plummet and fall back to zero so
something is holding up the galaxy well
outside where you see stars are okay
okay so these things I mean for this
thing to be flat this is called a
velocity curve for this curve to be flat
you basically need large amounts of mass
here here here here and and as and you
know as we going outside to the galaxy
we know that the Starlight is falling
off stars are getting fainter and
fainter you're losing I mean you're
reaching a visible edge to the galaxy
however the mass of the galaxy remember
it was the mass that was the crucial
thing he's not falling off okay so this
is the very very strong evidence for the
presence of dark matter so this is my
little cartoon to show you what our
current picture of galaxies is a current
picture of a galaxy so this is the star
light so this is a galaxy like ours it's
a spiral so where all the stars are
sitting okay so this is the densest part
where we see a lot of stars and as we go
further out the star light sort of oozes
off right you see the dim star light in
that image that I showed you and roughly
here you basically run out of stars but
then the velocity curve keeps going it
doesn't look like it's falling
it's suggestive of the fact that you
have something that looks like this you
have a huge halo of dark matter that is
around every galaxy and it appears and I
showed you just for random galaxies of
course these measurements have been made
for hundreds and thousands of galaxies
at the moment and you find that their
rotation curves the velocity curves are
flat so almost all galaxies seem to have
this kind of structure they have a huge
amount of dark matter yep sure but what
you can do is you can that's a very the
question I don't know if you all heard
it the question is of course you're
running out of stars so can you really
be sure the interesting thing is that a
lot of galaxies have satellite galaxies
so often although you've run out of the
stars of this particular galaxy you
would have a little neighboring galaxy
sort of sitting out here and when you
map the velocity of that guy around the
big galaxy you find that there is
evidence for a continuous curve that
shows you that there's a lot of dark
matter no it's not absolutely it's not a
vacuum and that's really that's what
it's so intriguing about dark matter
because it's clearly particles of some
sort right it's some kind of particles
we just don't know their mass we don't
know their charge well we know nothing
basically we know it exists and we can
roughly know that there's a lot of it
there's a lot of it and you might see
him how did she draw this edge so
clearly and that's really what I'm gonna
show you next which is the technique of
gravitational lensing which allows you
to say something about how far out this
whole halo of dark matter is sitting how
much dark matter do we really have okay
so that brings me on to the technique
that we're going to use to map dark
matter and the technique is one of
looking at the deflection of light from
sources
from objects in the universe and this
was something that was suspected by
Newton and Laplace and they said hmm so
the picture that they had roughly was
that you have this sort of space-time
sheet and you have galaxies that are
sitting so you think of it like I don't
know bread with raisins or something in
it okay so the galaxies are little
raisins or whatever and you're getting
light from all these different galaxies
we're sitting on earth in our solar
system we are measuring we are getting
by catching all this light we're
measuring these photons the question is
the path that these light rays take to
us will depend on the geometry of the
space-time between the galaxy and us so
if space-time was not flat and was like
a Pringle check and you have two people
sitting at each edge right and you have
another person sitting in the middle at
the top part of the Pringle the time
that it would take for light and the pot
that light would take would be a lot
more curvy for the one at the corner
than one at the center right and the
question is how can we look at the light
travel time from different places in the
universe and say something about the
shape of the universe okay and you might
say hmm and why why why would the light
travel times be different the geometry
is different okay why would the geometry
be different a different I already told
you that the shape of space-time is
determined by the mass blobs all the
blobs in the universe cause little bumps
in space-time okay therefore the
distribution so if I'm telling you that
there's a lot of dark matter and there
are lots of dark matter blogs they're
going to affect the path of light rays
and that is precisely what Einstein
figured out he didn't know about dark
matter but what he did know that if
there's any ordinary matter ordinary
atoms again I'm distinguishing dark
matter from something that's not made of
ordinary
Adams here we know that we know that
because if it was made of ordinary atoms
we would get some radiation either an
x-ray is a gamma rays you know or
something we don't right so we know that
dark matter is not made of ordinary
atoms but what Einstein calculated he
didn't know about dark matter but he
said suppose there was a big clump of
atoms like another galaxy that we just
haven't seen yet because it's faint or
whatever would its presence be felt by
this light travel time argument and he
calculated and he found that in fact yes
you know the the presence of any mass
whether it's dark matter or not would be
detectable just by looking at how much
the paths of light get deflected and you
might say yeah that's not interesting
but let's see so let me try and show you
the observational evidence and as well
build up a case for how people
discovered this effect of light bending
by masses okay by the presence of mass
sure in about 1979 there were these
three people who went and took a
spectrum and an image of a quasar of a
little patch of the sky and they saw
these two very bright images okay so the
quasar a quasar just to give you a quick
idea what it is it's a very very bright
object so these objects actually
outshine an entire galaxy the very point
like they're basically accreting black
holes okay they're very energetic
objects in the universe they are rare
but you do see them so they went and the
image this part of the sky and they
found these two objects they're like oh
that's great we found two quasars so
let's look at the characteristics let's
look at the spectrum of the light from
these two little shiny things in the
universe and let's try and figure out
what they are okay this respecter they
were quasars but then they said it's
pretty rare to find them that close
because these are rare objects so let's
see what's happening they looked at the
spectra of a and B they were identical
okay so they are in fact two images of
the same object because you can't have
the spectra be that identical if they
were different
objects because the spectra will tell
you why it no you can't but anyway so
what they found was the spectra were
absolutely identical and therefore they
had to be two images of the same object
and I said how can you have two images
of the same object I don't know if any
of you have done these experiments in
school where you have a candle you have
a screen and you have a lens you have I
know either concave lens or a convex
lens and as you keep moving the lens
between you and the candle you see very
different kinds of images of the same
candle right sometimes they candle looks
magnified sometimes it looks D magnified
sometimes it looks inverted sometimes it
looks as it is right depending on the
distance between the lens have you guys
done this experiment in optics simple
optics in scope so much similar to that
what's happening in the universe to make
the analogy just as you have this lens
that is focusing the light from the
candle to give you the image on the
screen in the universe the thing that
acts as the lens is mass is matter the
presence of matter is what focuses and D
focus is light if you if you have a
region of space that's a vacuum where
there is no matter at all then you will
tend to deep focus the light and every
time you have a max you tend to focus
the light very much like the lens the
only interesting thing in the universe
that's mathematically slightly different
is that you might end up seeing multiple
images of the same object which you
don't actually see in optics that
frequently okay you've told to make a
very elaborate arrangement in order to
do that whereas in the universe when
things line up just so so let me just
now try to put all the things we've
learned so far together so this is this
is a schematic of space-time
okay this black stuff this grid in
space-time so what you have is you have
us making a measurement this is this Sun
and you have a star that is behind the
Sun but we can get light from it okay
and the position
as viewed by earth we see the story here
and in fact the actual star is over here
on the reason we it appears to be here
is because the light has been bent and
it appears that the image of the star in
fact appears to be here the reason that
has happened the presence of mass in
this case it's the Sun has caused this
deflection okay so this is gravitational
lensing its gravitational because it's
caused by a mass and the mass that is
doing this light bending can be as wimpy
as the Sun as own fears a galaxy or as
extremely um free as many many galaxies
that are sitting close together in what
is called a cluster of galaxies all you
need is some mass and of course you will
see you will realize immediately is how
much bending you have is going to depend
on how massive this lens is how massive
this object is okay and of course
therefore the range of phenomena that
you're going to see whether you see two
images four images maybe more it's going
to depend on how massive this object is
it's also going to depend on how far we
are from the lens how far we are from
the source and what else is going to
depend on space-time the curvature the
shape of space-time okay and the reason
it's going to depend on space-time is
remember that almost any object in the
universe can act as a lens so if the
object is yep in straight lines
necessarily it travels in these these
curves that are called geodesics okay
that's a technical word and that
basically means that it follows the
curvature of space-time
so whatever bump but it it is absolutely
it's the straightest path it can find
given that you have a curved geometry so
if the space-time is kind of curvy
that's the shortest path that the light
can find to us okay
and as I said this deflection the extent
of this
action depends very very strongly on the
mass of this lens and that's what's
going to be crucial remember I keep
saying mass why do I keep saying mass
sorry there's a question in the back up
right right as far as we are concerned
because the the distance the difference
on any different five points in the
earth is going to be tiny compared to
any of these distances that won't be
consequential sure so what you do is you
make a measurement of the total light
within a fixed aperture okay that and
you you have ways we have ways to
calculate how much of the light has
leaked out into this diffraction pattern
so nowadays the optics on telescopes are
so sophisticated that all of that
correction is done Institue on the
telescope in the lenses okay so as I
said I keep coming back to mass and
saying oh look the mass of the object is
what determines how much deflection so
you can see where I'm going right if I
want to tell you how much dark matter
there is that there is dark matter the
evidence is going to be the deflections
we see in the universe so I'm hoping to
now show you some beautiful pictures of
deflections but before we move on I just
thought one of you might end up asking
me this question is that it's the
precise configuration of the lens us and
the object from which the light is
coming that gives you the range of
phenomena that I'm going to show you the
many sets of multiple images sometimes
when things are just so you can end up
seeing something that's called an
Einstein ring you can end up seeing an
individual distant object which is
actually a point source stretched out
it's light stretched out into a complete
ring anyway that's strange would we see
that
before I start showing you pictures let
me show you that you know this game as I
said of trying to map what is the mass
that's causing the light deflection can
be done on different scales it can be
done with us in the Sun and a star
behind it can be done and has been very
successfully done by an experiment that
has looked to see how much dark matter
our own galaxy might have right so we
are sitting here this is okay we're
sitting right here it's the center of
our galaxy now if we had a huge dark
matter halo what do we have to do we
have to look at some stars that are far
enough away that we can actually see
them get the light from them and then
see if you have say dark matter with
these kind of blobs then these blobs
would cause deflections and all we have
to do is measure the deflections right
and say okay how big is our dark matter
halo so yes there isn't it there have
been many experiments that have done
that and there are some very interesting
results but what I want to now show you
is how we've just moved on to looking at
these deflections in the universe that
are telling us why the dark matter in
the universe is so this is that special
case that I showed you that once in a
while when things line up just so you
have the Einstein ring which is the
image of a galaxy that has been
stretched so they actually two images
but it's been stretched to form what
looks like almost a complete ring and of
course it's called the Einstein ring
because Einstein calculated that this
should happen very rarely but it should
it happens very rarely but this is the
first one that was observed so in this
case the object that is lensed is a
quasar okay and the mass that is lensing
it is a galaxy it's a galaxy between us
and the quasars okay
and this the fact that you have these
two images and you have it stretched out
like this allows you to figure out how
much mass this galaxy has to have in
order to accomplish this and when we do
that you get a number and that is 10
times 250 times more than all the
Starlight that you see in this galaxy
you can add up the mass from the star
light you can add up
mass of all the stars in that galaxy and
you find that the mass that you need for
it to accomplish this lensing is 10 to
50 times more than what you see so and
this is not the only case as I said this
is the rare event but there are many
more common events where you find
incontrovertible evidence for large
amounts of dark matter yeah sure it
actually it includes it's very
sophisticated what people do they are
calculating this quantity called
mass-to-light ratio which depends on the
age of the star the mass of the star
helped make the stories and you know
that stars form with different masses
and there's an aggregate of them so all
of that is taken into account
absolutely it's also taken into account
that some stars will not shine invisible
they were child in the infrared and so
on so forth all of that taken into
account and you still find that you know
you need a large amount of dark matter
you might say hey she's shown us a
one-off right no in fact it happens
quite a lot in the universe but you know
you get different configurations each
time you don't get the same because you
know the the job the distance between us
and the lens and so on is different so
you get very different phenomena but
here you get four images of the same
object and this is the lensing galaxy
you get an arc sometimes you get a
highly distorted arc okay and you get
just one you get one very magnified
brightened one you get one dimmed one
you get two images you get a whole range
of images okay and from these images we
are able to map how much mass you really
need but let me just move on before I
finish up to the grandest scale on which
we are seeing this light deflection and
what that's telling us about dark matter
in the universe okay so and in fact I
want to point out that this is sort of
my particular area of research which is
trying to look at the distribution of
dark matter in fact trying to map all
the little clumps ok the details of all
the little clumps and the reason why you
know map
all those little clumps is interesting
and important is because just how clumpy
things are might tell you something
about the nature of dark matter remember
we know nothing about it so far so
that's really this is sort of one of the
sort of hot problems in the field of
cosmology today which is trying to get
you know ways of mapping the Dark Matter
getting how many clumps there are how
they're distributed to see if we can
eventually kind of narrow down on the
nature of dark matter figure out what
it's made of
so anyway clusters of galaxies this is
an image of a cluster a cluster of
galaxies in fact contains mostly dark
matter as we will see in a minute just
from the amount of light deflection you
see in it you can tell because you can
once again add up all the Starlight it's
not enough we act as gravitational
lenses or telescopes because room where
a telescope basically has a lens right
it's focusing the light that's what a
telescope does and what all these
wonderful objects in the universe are
doing for us are acting as telescopes
the acting as lenses is light collecting
areas right and what is very interesting
is that they also offer you a very
interesting and powerful window in the
universe one of the things that the
effect of lensing is that it also
magnifies the object exactly what a lens
that's why we call it that's why we have
used the word lens it's actually
magnifies the objects so I want to end
by showing you the image of the farthest
galaxy ever found in the universe and it
was found behind a lens and the only
reason we found it is because it
happened to be behind the lens it's so
faint we would not have found it with
current technology okay so that's what
that's another incredible thing about
this effect aside from the fact that we
are mapping you know the presence of
vast amounts of dark matter make these
objects very good lenses and so they're
magnifying things that are really faint
that are behind them for us which we
would otherwise not see at all okay so
let me just tell you what a cluster is
oh this is just a few more images and I
one more thing I wanted to show
dimension to you is this light bending
is independent of the wavelength in
you see the image so you would you can
see it in the radio this is all in radio
wavelengths this is looking at a map
looking at these quasars in the radio
and you see all these multiple images
you know you see it in the visible you
see it in the x-ray you see it in the
radio okay so this is and the
interesting thing is it's a chromatic
doesn't depend on the wavelength of the
light that's emitted by the object okay
so what the cluster so the composition
of a cluster and that we know at the
moment is about 1% of the mass is in
galaxies in stars and galaxies 10% of
the mass is in hot gas that's kind of
held together by the gravity of the
cluster the rest is all dark matter so
these are very very interesting objects
if we want to look at gravitational
light deflections because these are
going to be the most efficient lenses
for us of course our questions are you
know how much mass how much how much of
that is dark and how is it distributed
so this is just to show you a little
animation of what happens when you have
a screen of galaxies that are behind a
cluster which is very massive which has
a lot of galaxies and this just shows
you the range of depending on your each
of these frames is slightly different
because I've moved things around a
little bit okay to show you that you see
a whole range of deflections okay so
this this is telling you that basically
a galaxy will have will be spread out
and will be torn into this arc would be
magnified so this is what this is the
image you would see so I want you to
hold this okay this is a simulation
okay now I'll be showing you real
clusters and I back to you all of you
will be able to pick up the images
that's how dramatic it is now that you
know roughly what these multiple images
so right around the center of the
cluster
you see these many multiple images in
this as I as you seen this animation so
let me just show you very quickly you
can see immediately okay have we seen
something like this before
yeah this is in fact a very very nice
lens arc sent individual galaxies that
has been stretched
doubt and once again you know I'm
telling you the story now post facto
when observations people admitted right
away and they did the calculations and
said iris lensing it wasn't that easy
this was this object was seen it was
considered to be a very mysterious giant
orc and they hadn't figured out that
this was probably a lens image this was
in the 70s and this is from and this is
the close-up of a cluster in the central
regions of a cluster and this is another
one and this is a very dramatic one I'll
show you another picture of it a Hubble
Space Telescope picture so already once
people had accepted that this could be
gravitational lensing they started doing
the mass inventory and they said gosh
the clusters are much more massive
because they were able to catch how much
dark matter there was in the clusters
and remember the bulk is so this is one
of the best studied gravitational lenses
in the universe this is a cluster of
galaxies and everyone can see the
distorted images right see them here
here see all the arcs see the arcs
around here so in this particular field
of frame that we're seeing there are 17
sets of multiple images ok that gives
you a really good handle on the
distribution of mass and all matter in
this region of space ok and this is
another one so these are all Hubble
Space Telescope images so you can see
here here here you can see all the arcs
and you can probably tell right away
just from the number that you see here
that this cluster is probably not as
massive as a previous one we saw and you
would be right so let me show me you
show you a couple more and I'll show you
a little bit of a close-up and show you
sort of roughly what you know
cosmologists study what about these
images do we study so this is that image
that I just showed you so what we work
on is trying and model this arc this is
the arc and I've removed all the other
stuff just to close in on the arc and
what you do is you solve the equations
when you put in the amount of mass that
is needed and you have to match what is
observed
you have to match the length of this arc
the curvature of this arc the shape of
this arc as well as the detailed
distribution of the light along this arc
that's what we do in the modeling and
that's what tells you how much mass and
that is determined by how much dark
matter basically you have and how its
distributed so it's a very very nice fun
mathematical problem which is very well
constrained solvable so this is actually
my favorite cluster it has five sets of
multiple images of the same galaxy the
interesting thing is that this galaxy
that is multiplied imaged is a very
interesting galaxy in itself it's
actually sort of it's a ring galaxy
shape like a little cartwheel and is
that amazing you see the same structure
in all the five images remember I told
you that if we already know by looking
at the spectra of all of these that they
are in fact they confirm that they're
all multiple images of the same galaxy
so this is another of the current
clusters this I just wanted to show you
one slide of my work so that you have an
idea of what it is that I actually do so
what I do what you see here is an image
from the Hubble Space Telescope that are
sort of these dark patches those are the
galaxies in the cluster and what you see
here is my model for the dark matter and
what you see are these circles are the
halos of dark matter around these
individual galaxies that you need to
have in order to produce the lensing
that is seen okay and so this is the
kind of work that is done sand now this
is the kind of detailed map that we have
so now we know that the dark matter is
kind of blobby there are these blobs
these little red circles tell you how
big the Dark Matter halos are and we
know they're quite a lot of blobs very
blobby so now what we're all working on
is try and figure out what the
implications are if the dark matter is
so blobby what could it be made of if we
know that it has to be so blobby and not
smooth right it's not smooth it's
actually very very blobby I think I have
just two more slides before I wrap up
this is um as I was putting things
together for you all yesterday
got an email from Space Telescope
Science Institute saying hey we
discovered this new funky lens what do
you think and I said oh gosh I have to
show this so this is not you know
cleaned up etc etc yet but this is fresh
off the telescope so this is a blends
that was discovered last week it's a
cluster of galaxies which is in fact
very far away from us it's farther than
all the other clusters that I've shown
you so when you think about the
configuration the lens is very far from
us and the source is even further behind
we are looking we're looking back to a
time when the universe was 15 percent of
its current age that's how far back
we're looking that's a very good
question
I should have mentioned that okay so
this is just a zoom in of that you know
galaxies that I showed you in the lens
and this is my last slide remember I
told you that one of the other things
that the lenses can help you do is to by
chance allow you to see some very faint
objects that you would not otherwise see
because you magnify the light and so
what has been the highest redshift
galaxy that has been conclusively imaged
and discovered is one where discovered
at a redshift which is it's quite far
away it is at a distance from us where
we could not have directly imaged it if
it wouldn't happen to be sitting behind
this lens we just won't have discovered
with current technology maybe in ten
years time we would but at the moment we
wouldn't have okay so this is the
youngest object if you will in the
universe the earliest sort of galaxies
that formed that we have direct light
from at the moment so yep
yes absolutely there has been a lot of
research and there are a lot of models
on trying to characterize what might be
a relevant time scale and spacial scale
over which gravity so there these
theories called modified Newtonian
dynamics which deal with that and we can
talk a little bit if you want to know a
little bit about what's down at the
moment they are considered slightly
speculative theories at the moment
because they don't actually fit in
comfortably with all the data that is
seen one can argue that it fits with
some pieces of data but not with others
well it doesn't appear to be a finite
speed at the moment no there's no
evidence but there are people who are
working on models yep
that's a very nice question yeah
no it's a very good question the
question is you know what are the
dynamical properties of dark matter
we understand quite a lot about that and
it appears that dark matter just behaves
only well gravity so you can start off
only be a gravity the interact only we
are gravity and the entire dynamics and
evolution is determined only by gravity
and and the way we know that is because
we have these very large computational
simulations in which we can start off
with an initial sort of universe
condition universe please remember we
know that the dark matter dominates the
universe so you can start off with a lot
of particles of dark matter let them go
let them evolve with time and see if
they would cluster into these halos and
in fact they do they cluster very well
into these halos so just gravity seems
to do the trick in describing all the
dynamics for dark matter